hey guys Ryan right here and tonight I'm
gonna be watching the trailer for this I
guess highly anticipated comedy let's be
cops I don't know anything about it
except for the fact that Damon Wayans
not Damon when Damien Wayans I think is
who it is or Damon Wayans Jr can't
remember the [__] which Wayans brother
it is I'm sure the preview will tell me
I want to see this trailer really bad
because a lot of people have been asking
me to but I want to take a moment to do
a little shout-out to a couple of
subscribers Kevin market and Victoria
black you guys comment a lot but for
some reason wall let me reply back so so
I want to tell you guys that right now
whenever I click the thumbs up button on
your comments I have read that comment
and I really want to respond three
minutes of comedy remember when we said
if we didn't make a bedtime over 30 we
would move back to Ohio yeah or 30 is
[__] right now track what are you
talking about we riot things going on
right now did I see you the commercial
cheated yeah I had I have I have general
Herbie's that punch look really weak you
don't jump out on brothers man no I
can't so we're gonna re tonight he's
playing a black guy in this movie let's
be cops we look ridiculous
I feel like Danny Glover before he got
too old for this [__] so lovely the
weapons is miss right party that's the
same thing not the same not a saint
what are you a [__] cancer is this
for real
I'm sorry I had no idea that you were a
cop aren't you man yo mr. love cheers
Cheers yeah I would totally do all this
[__] stay hey baby it's a super league
all right this note Wow oh nice
20 little pricks asking what I do all
day he's a cop Ron he ain't [__] [__]
you rock Oh
jail for years for this [__] Oh serving
to progress yes no yes let's get a
female early 20s possibly intoxicated
sweet oh yeah oh damn you bad words
gonna be a ton of fun
I gotta tell you something I'm not God
okay I I am a cop holy [__] I'm a cop
another chicken oh yeah thank you
it's my sister's control the situation
don't you get what you get
oh we are way to August aw man okay
movie guys look really oh [__] my
camera's about to die um yeah a movie
looks [__] hilarious
I gotta speed this up now it dude it is
like exactly how I want to live my life
it sounds pathetic when you kind of say
that out loud but overall in that that
just can't I just it seems like
something I might one day do yeah I
think you guys are recommending that
trailer keep suggesting more and if
you're new the channel because scrubs
subscribe please it sounds like I mean
desperate subscribe please please
subscribe I was of the grind I like the
people to subscribe because we talk and
we have a great time every time we
interact it's a fun new and a bunch of
movie lovers dude anyway I got sawed off
my camera I'm gonna be watching Noah
tonight what's salamanders Sally and I
hope it's good and we're gonna do a
review of that this weekend keep a look
out for those reviews people it's cool
they got like a white cup and a black
cop so that way you'll get the white
audience and the black audience